finally thanks to this judge catherine
kimball-mizell the totally unjustified
anti-science federal mass mandate was
finally put out of its misery this week
now the experts are saying of course no
one should be wearing a cloth mask
listen to this
they can also hand out free n95s or k95s
and the equivalent masks because these
high quality masks if you're going to
wear a mask wear a high quality mask
people should not be wearing a cloth
mask thinking that they're well
protected
did you hear that people should not be
wearing a cloth mask thinking that
they're well protected now yes exactly
that's what some of us were saying two
years ago when experts like that
were accusing those who questioned the
effectiveness of cloth masks of pushing
medical misinformation that was killing
people but even as the political media
and medical establishment lectured the
rest of us their own behavior showed
that they knew they were lying remember
this grotesque scene from a fundraising
lunch hosted by nancy antoinette in napa
valley last summer where the rich white
woke democrat donors lounged around
maskless where the only people of color
the democrats never stopped going on
about were the people serving them their
champagne and canopies all forced to
wear masks so disgusting so utterly
decadent they knew the cloth masks were
a waste of time that's why they didn't
wear them at the hair salon
having dinner at the french laundry
about the nightclub when they were
feeling the spirit
masks for the working class maskless for
the ruling class and then they were
literally unmasked as the snooty
despicable elitist they really are now
finally the madness is over thanks to
that federal judge in florida which
reminds us just how important our
constitution really is
decentralization of power checks and
balances but of course the control craze
technocrats and bureaucrats can't stand
it just as we pry away their pandemic
power grabs finger by finger they
desperately try to claw it back lunatic
anti-science mania still in progressive
cities around the country that san diego
mts will still require mosques same
thing in new york the mta taxis and now
in a laughable attempt to save face
biden is having his own justice
department appeal the mask ruling with
the cdc saying the masks are necessary
for the public health cloth masks
necessary for public health these people
have so discredited themselves of the
past two years it is clear that the cdc
is not necessary for the public health
the cdc was once known as the world's
leading public health agency what a joke
i'd get better health advice from my
chickens
and the public health bureaucrats just
can't take the fact that no one trusts
them anymore here's former cdc director
tom frieden whining on npr
what we've seen over the past few years
is partisanship
infecting
individual measures like vaccination and
masking and more broadly public health
measures
oh it's partisanship that's destroyed
trust in public health bureaucrats is it
no tom frieden you've done it all on
your own
by denying science and relentlessly
pushing ineffective
unjustified micromanagement of our lives
look if people want to keep wearing
their masks whatever in america that is
of course their right just as long as
they never dare lecture the rest of us
ever again about believing the science
when it comes to covid climate or
anything else
but exactly as it is their right to make
their own decisions it is our right to
that's what the constitution guarantees
and so it was a fitting end to this week
of humiliation for the failed medical
establishment when fauci popped up and
pooped off about how terrible it all is
that a judge had the temerity to
overrule them
and we are concerned about that about
courts getting involved in things that
are unequivocally public health
decisions i mean this is a cdc issue
it's not should not have been a court
issue
we are concerned was that the royal we
he literally declared that he thinks
he's above the law it is that kind of
arrogance
that most likely created the pandemic in
the first place fauci recklessly
commissioning gain of function research
in wuhan breaking obama and trump
administration rules when will fauci and
all the other arrogant bureaucrats
who've caused so much pain death and
destruction be held accountable
tell us what you think at steve hilton x
and at next rev fnc and share this
message when we post it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else